The man was Ian Fleming.
Born May 28, 1908 to a wealthy family in London,
he and his three brothers were educated at
Eton College, the same school Princes William
and Harry attended.
Fleming was supposedly a master of athletics.
After Eton, he attended Sandhurst and chose
to study in Munich and Geneva, where he had
the Alps as a backdrop.
He would later learn to ski and climb the
mountains, perhaps not surprising given his
athletic history, which would also set the
stage for some of his yet-to-be-conceived
character in the James Bond books.
Fleming jumped from career to career almost
as often as he switched girlfriends.
He was known to be a “womaniser,” not
that the ladies seemed to mind—apparently
they thought him very attractive.
In this way, he didn’t differ much from
Bond himself.
He first tried to establish himself in the
military, followed by an attempt to become
a foreign diplomat—both were unsuccessful.
He later enjoyed a stint working for Reuters,
where he learned basic journalism skills and
covered a case about a Russian spy.
However, he knew there wasn’t a lot of money
to be had in journalism—at least not for
him—and he decided to pursue a career as
a stockbroker.
However, the world was fast approaching World
War II.
Despite the fact that his father had died
while serving in World War I when Fleming
was just nine, it didn’t deter him from
entering the war effort when World War II
broke out.
He started out as a Lieutenant Commander RNVR
in Naval Intelligence, gathering information
that helped the smooth-running of the Allied
war effort.
He later became the personal assistant to
the director.
His work took him on many overseas visits,
notably to the United States where he had
a hand in the establishment of what would
become the CIA.
Specifically, while on a trip to D.C., Fleming
worked with a group to come up with a blueprint
for the Office of the Coordinator of Intelligence—a
department that eventually evolved into the
CIA.
Much of what Fleming learned during his time
with Naval Intelligence likely helped to shape
the Bond books, though Fleming was never able
to speak openly about his work because he
signed the Official Secrets Act.
However, it is thought that his director,
Admiral John Godfrey, was the inspiration
for the character M. In Diamonds are Forever,
published in 1956, where he wrote, “There
was a creak from M’s chair and Bond looked
across the table at the man who held a great
deal of his affection and all his loyalty
and obedience.”
After the war, Fleming had taken up a job
as the Foreign Manager of The Sunday Times,
but he started talking about wanting to write
“the spy novel to end all spy novels.”
No doubt after his experiences during the
war, in which he liaised with spies but never
truly became one, he had quite a lot of fodder
waiting to be turned into a book.
Before any writing could be accomplished,
however, Fleming decided to get his life in
order.
First, he negotiated a contract with his employers
that allowed him three months off a year.
Then, he started building a house in Jamaica.
He’d fallen in love with the country when
he visited during a naval intelligence meeting
and vowed to return someday.
Naming his house Goldeneye, after a mission
during the war, he settled in to write.
Some say that he started writing the novels
to impress his soon-to-be wife, Ann, Lady
Rothermere.
He had been having an affair with Ann for
several years.
After she became pregnant with their second
child (the first was stillborn) she divorced
her husband and joined Fleming in Jamaica.
But Ann had surrounded herself with writers
in London, and perhaps he thought publishing
a book would allow him into that circle.
Whatever the case, the first James Bond novel,
Casino Royale, was published in 1953.
It was written in just two months while Fleming
was on “vacation” in Jamaica, a trend
he continued for subsequent books.
He kept on working for The Sunday Times until
1959, using his three months’ vacation to
write.
The job was actually pretty useful for his
book writing career: it allowed him to connect
with people from all over the world, so he
was able to check facts about geography, history,
and culture with people who lived in the areas
he was writing if he was not able to visit
himself.
This, along with his tendency to include brands
of items in his books, added a level of realism
to his stories.
For the most part, the popularity of the books
rose steadily, though they received a few
big surges as well.
First, President John F. Kennedy cited From
Russia With Love as one of his favourite reads,
resulting in sales rising sharply in the United
States.
(Incidentally, he actually met President Kennedy
and the First Lady in Washington, D.C. and
reported that it was one of his favourite
fan encounters.)
Secondly, the first James Bond movie—Dr.
No—was released in 1962, starring the talented
Sean Connery as Bond.
Fleming would also live to see From Russia
With Love made into a hit film, as well as
some of the filming of Goldfinger.
Many more Bond films have since been created,
of course, with a range of actors playing
the title character including, most recently,
Daniel Craig.
But Fleming wouldn’t live to see exactly
how huge his books—and subsequent movies—would
become.
He was suffering from heart disease and had
his first heart attack in 1962.
Told not to work during his recovery, he started
writing a book on the sly for his only son,
Caspar, who was ten at the time.
Was this his next great Bond book or perhaps
some sort of “James Bond Jr.” novel geared
for a younger audience?
Nope.
The adventuresome novel was a fantastical
tale about a flying car: Chitty Chitty Bang
Bang.
This book would, of course, go on to be made
into a movie that would become a family classic,
but Fleming was never able to see it for himself.
Ian Fleming died on his son’s twelfth birthday—August
12, 1964—after suffering from many different
health issues.
Needless to say, that was quite the traumatic
experience for a boy to suffer at such a young
age, and Caspar was plagued by mental health
issues in his teen years until he committed
suicide in 1975 at the age of 23.
Nevertheless, Fleming’s legacy lives on.
His Bond books as well as Chitty Chitty Bang
Bang have never left print.
Fleming proved to be a talented writer whose
books were able to stand the test of time
with great descriptions, interesting characters,
and an engaging plot.
In an article about how to write a thriller,
Fleming said it was easy:
There is only one recipe for a best seller.
You have to get the reader to turn over the
page.
The name “James Bond” is actually that
of an ornithologist.
Originally, Fleming wanted James bond to be
a boring, ordinary man who happened to experience
some extraordinary things.
He knew about an ornithologist named James
Bond from Bond’s book, Birds of the West
Indies, which he had read in his youth and
thought the author’s name was one of the
most boring names he’d ever heard.
However, the boring name soon became rather
exciting.
Mrs. Ornithologist Bond actually sent Fleming
a letter thanking him for using the name.
Fleming wasn’t the only writer in his family.
His elder brother, Peter, made a career out
of travel writing.
He also has two nephews and a niece who are
published authors.